[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti grazie per la vostra
presenza enuncio subito le intenzioni da
cui nasce questo
discorso la prima intenzione è quella di
svelare alcune delle numerose
illusioni sulle quali galleggia la
nostra
esistenza la seconda intenzione è quella
di
avvicinarci per quanto è possibile
all'immenso
oceano della
realtà espresso dalla formula
tutto in
tutto questa formula non è mia è
dell'Antico grande filosofo greco
anassagora
coniata circa
2500 anni fa che nel corso della storia
appare
periodicamente nelle pagine di alcuni
dei più importanti filosofi
dell'Occidente EAV
questa formula non è mai la visione di
mondo che essa esprime non è mai
divenuta patrimonio
culturale pensiero diffuso e dominante
nell'occidente al contrario è
rimasta se
non
l'opposto di ciò che pensiamo
comunemente quantomeno una formula
paradossale
Perché Perché gli uomini hanno bisogno
di illudersi
Vi presento ora due generi principali di
illusioni La prima è quella che crede
che il mondo sia così come ci
appare per spiegarmi
rapidamente guardate questa
immagine a destra a sinistra voi avete
una margherita vista
dall'uomo a destra la stessa Margherita
vista da
un'ape vedete che i colori sono
completamente
diversi c'è un'altra
immagine è un
paesaggio sopra visto dall'uomo
sotto visto dal gatto e ancora una terza
immagine un cane visto dall'uomo mentre
è sdraiato su un tappeto erboso verde e
lo stesso cane come si vedrebbe se
potesse vedersi con i suoi
occhi l'erba allora come è verde o è
giallo grigia come la vede il
cane
un campo di papaveri è rosso come lo
vede l'uomo o di un colore tra il viola
e l'ultravioletto come lo vedono le api
la risposta è
netta Il Papavero non è né rosso né
ultravioletto diciamo così l'erba non è
verde ciascun
Senziente reagisce in relazione al
proprio sistema
visivo alla alle variazioni di luce
che
sono provenienti dagli
oggetti un sistema visivo umano
interpreta quella certa luce in un certo
modo e il sistema visivo del gatto in un
altro
modo Dunque il mondo non è colorato I
colori sono nella nostra mente e quello
che dico per la vista vale per tutti i
sensi
sicché quando noi diciamo che l'erba è
verde
e noi non diciamo una cosa giusta perché
l'erba non è verde non
è giallo grigia e C di nessun altro
colore l'erba non ha colore nessuna cosa
ha
colore
se domani le maestre e i maestri
cominciassero a correggere i tabelloni
che sono nelle aule scolastiche e
insegnassero ai loro
allievi che l'erba non è verde ma appare
verde questo concetto
dell'apparire avvierebbe una rivoluzione
culturale e civile dalla portata credo
inestimabile Ma parliamo di un altro
genere di
illusioni sono
quelle che noi Formiamo ci Formiamo
attribuendo alla realtà esterna idee che
appartengono esclusivamente alla la
nostra mente e che la mente formula
Conia Foggia come strumenti per potersi
orientare nel mare immenso
dell'esperienza attorno a noi c'è un
movimento
infinito noi non siamo in grado di
rappresentare tutto questo movimento
Allora abbiamo inventato uno strumento
che ci consente di disporre il movimento
secondo il prima e il dopo questo
strumento si chiama
tempo ma il tempo non sta fuori di noi
il tempo è in
noi Noi abbiamo relazione con molte cose
e queste cose entrano in relazione con i
nostri bisogni con i nostri desideri con
le nostre attese E da questo
derivano rappresentazioni
Sul rapporto tra le cose e noi stessi e
Allora diciamo che una cosa è bella una
cosa è brutta una cosa È ordinata una
certa situazione è disordinata eccetera
eccetera
tutte le rappresentazioni
estetiche esistono soltanto nella nostra
mente e guai a attribuire alle cose ciò
che appartiene alla nostra
mente ma ci sono anche altre
rappresentazioni per esempio quelle
morali quando noi diciamo che le cose
che una certa cosa è buona un'altra è
cattiva le cose non sono né buone e né
cattive essere buono cattivo indica
soltanto la relazione tra quella cosa E
noi
stessi per cui ci accade nel corso del
tempo che è una cosa che Ci sembrava un
tempo Buona ora ci sembri cattiva e
viceversa ora Vedete se noi non siamo in
grado di riconoscere questo
meccanismo che è un meccanismo di leggi
naturali e cadiamo nella illusione
E noi siamo in qualche modo fuori dalla
realtà ci comportiamo rispetto alla nuda
realtà
come come persone che vagano che
brancolano un po' nel buio ma vi voglio
parlare di un'illusione particolare di
un'illusione
fondamentale sulla quale si è costruita
la storia dell'Occidente è come un
cardine su cui abbiamo
appeso le nostre
convinzioni le nostre verità le nostre
attese non solo per questa vita ma anche
per quella Futura è la nozione di
sostanza
sostanza Noi siamo abituati a pensare
che le cose siano sostanze Noi siamo
sostanze Il gatto è una sostanza questo
castello è una sostanza che cosa vuol
dire sostanza sostanza vuol dire a
partire da Aristotele che si tratta di
un ente che è in sé e che non è in
altro tutto ciò che è altro e che non è
in sé si può e si deve riferire alla
sostanza è la famosa distinzione tra
sostanza e
accidente ora
[Applauso]
vedete la filosofia moderna a cominciare
dalla metà del 400 con Cusano fino alla
fine del 700 con Kant ha sottoposto a
critica radicale l'idea di sostanza
finita cioè l'idea che le cose finite
fossero
sostanze Spinoza nell'etica scrive
l'uomo non è una sostanza Y dice la
sostanza è una pura finzione Insomma non
Esistono sostanze e allora come mai Noi
continuiamo benché siano passati 2 3 4 5
secoli continuiamo a pensare ancora con
questa categoria
fondamentale perché ripeto con su questa
categoria Abbiamo costruito alcuni dei
cardini di riferimento della nostra
cultura pensate per esempio all'ambito
teologico della nozione di sostanza ci
serviamo per spiegare la differenza
nella Trinità tra l'unità delle tre
persone in quanto sostanza di
e la differenza appunto delle persone
sull'idea di sostanza è fondato il dogma
della transustanziazione cioè la
trasformazione della sostanza del pane
nella sostanza del corpo di Cristo della
sostanza del vino nella sostanza del
sangue di Cristo ma Voi capite che noi
non potremmo tenere in
piedi diciamo così la
teologia
della vita futura se non pensassimo che
l'anima umana è una sostanza spirituale
capace di permanere dopo la morte del
corpo Allora capite anche che se noi
elimino il concetto di sostanza come
sarebbe da fare
crollerebbe gran parte dei nostri
riferimenti culturali
Se l'idea di sostanza va cambiata Come
va cambiata Da che cosa va sostituita
Ecco
vi come dire vi racconto in un minuto
che cosa scrive
l'ibn Forse il più grande genio dell'età
moderna in una sua operetta del
1714 sapete l'in pensava che l'universo
fosse
fatto di realtà semplici o come anche le
Chiama sostanze semplici che sono in
estese non sono corporee non sono corpi
sono
forze Forze
energie le quali sono in relazione con
tutte le altre infinite sostanze ecco
vedete è come se fosse stato pensato in
anticipo Un immagine per spiegare la
relazione che l'ibn pone tra queste
sostanze semplici che cosa dice l'ims
dice che ogni sostanza semplice può
essere
pensata
come un incrocio di Infinito di angoli
di angoli assurdo se è in esteso Come
fanno a esserci angoli No questo accade
perché ogni ogni punto è attraversato
dalla relazione con altri punti
e siccome le relazioni sono
infinite le rette che passano per ogni
punto sono infinite e Provenendo le
rette da qualsiasi direzione creano
angoli infiniti Dunque l'ibn sostituisce
in realtà la nozione di sostanza con la
nozione di
relazione ma andiamo oltre
come è
possibile che
queste monadi o realtà
semplici possano
esistere esistono da sé o sono
espressione di altro secondo leibniz
sono espressione di altro perché la
potenza che esse esprimono è non è la
loro perché ciascuna di esse ha una
potenza finita
determinata ma sono espressioni di una
potenza infinita
assoluta che appunto si manifesta
attraverso questa infinità di centri di
Potenza posti in relazione l'uno con
l'altro e che
cos'è questa potenza infinita o assoluta
è il modo con il quale la filosofia
moderna a partire da
Cusano quel Cusano che nessuno studia
nelle
scuole secondarie nei corsi di filosofia
Ma è un errore
gravissimo quel Cusano che negli ultimi
giorni della sua
vita scopre un segreto
profondissimo ossia che
l'essenza prima di tutte le cose non è
niente altro che potenza Posse Ipsum la
potenza in quanto tale senza
determinazioni quindi non una potenza di
pensare una potenza di conoscere una
potenza di essere steso la potenza allo
stato puro e questa potenza lo stato
puro costituisce l'ac quidditas
l'essenza della realtà e tutto ciò che
si manifesta Che cos'è il latino lo
definisce apparizio apparizione
manifestazione potremmo dire per
ritornare alle battute iniziali
è l'apparenza
dell'infinito che di per sé è
inapparente cioè possiamo conoscerlo
solo con l'intelletto
per farvi
capire questo
concetto posso ricorrere a un esempio
gli esempi In filosofia non dovrebbero
mai essere presentati ma certe volte
sono utili e allora l'esempio che vi
voglio presentare è quello del rapporto
tra l'oceano e le sue
onde voi avete tutti esperienza del mare
Ecco io ho Vi propongo un'immagine
che se arriva
eh ci farà capire qual è questo
rapporto tra
una onda e l'altra
onda esiste differenza certo un'onda è
diversa dall'altra
onda tra un'onda e il mare esiste
differenza certo un'onda non è il mare
Ma l'acqua di un'onda è diversa
dall'acqua del mare no è la stessa acqua
e l'acqua di un'onda è diversa
dall'acqua dell'altra
onda No non è diversa e allora Voi
capite
che tra tutto ciò che ci appare diverso
c'è qualcosa di comune in questo caso
comune è l'acqua e allora ciascuna Onda
è nel mare come il mare è in ciascuna
onda e come ciascuna onda È nell'altra
onda
attraverso
la sussistenza e la
permanenza di ciascun
determinato nell'assoluto infinito che
qui abbiamo chiamato mare ma noi
dovremmo chiamare potenza
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
n